See, your pattern is scored based on the number 10, so out of 10 is your mark.
As you can see, it's split up into two parts, we have our accuracy and our presentation
on this side.
So we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So your accuracy is actually scored from a 4, so from the number 4, you're actually marked
during your presentation of your pattern, and then with that one, any mistakes that
you make, if it's a minor mistake, you get a minus of a 0.1, if it's a major mistake,
you get minus 0.3.
So I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two.
So with a minor mistake, it's a very, very small thing.
So say we're doing a powder block, if it's not your shoulder height, maybe it's a little
bit lower.
Or maybe it's a tiny bit higher, that's a minor mistake, so that's a 0.1.
A major mistake would be, you're supposed to do an out-of-block in the pattern, but
you forget and you say you do a reach-hand strike instead.
So that would be a major mistake.
So with a minor mistake, let's say pattern 1, for example, there's about 20 steps, it's
not uncommon to have up to maybe 14, 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns, sorry, in the 20 steps.
So the reason for that one?
That means it needs to be absolutely perfect to not get a deduction of 0.1.
So it's not uncommon, let's say there's 20 steps and you made, let's say, 15 mistakes.
So what would that be?
So we'll leave that there on this side, and we'll come back and we'll just calculate the
square at the end.
So a major mistake, say you're supposed to turn to the left, but you turn to the right,
that would be a major mistake.
So obviously, we do want to try to avoid any of these major mistakes.
So after we've done our pattern, that's when we move on to the presentation side.
So the presentation, as you can see, it's from a score of 6.
This 6 is actually split up into three parts.
So we have 1, 2, 3 here.
So with this one, for a score of 2 is your power and speed.
Your rhythm is also a score of 2.
And your expression of energy is also scored out in 3.
So we'll start off with the power and speed.
So with this one, whether it's your blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches, anything
that you do, you need to be nice and strong, and it has to be fast as well.
So it's one thing to have a very strong punch, or a very fast punch, but it has to be both
strong and fast to get high in that category.
The next part is your rhythm.
So the rhythm.
When you do start your pattern, there is a rhythm to the rhythm.
It's not just really fast all the way through, it's not slow all the way through, there's
a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of aspect to it as well.
So you do need to kind of work on your rhythm, and that's also scored out of 2.
The last bit is your expression of energy.
So what is expression of energy?
So that's basically how loud you shout, so how much intensity you have during your pattern
as well.
So say you're doing your pattern really well.
It's really fast and it's strong.
Your rhythm is really great, but you're not shouting very loud, or you can kind of tell,
the judges can kind of tell, oh you're not really confident, you're a little bit nervous,
so that's what we need to kind of improve on as well.
So I'm just coming onto this side.
So with this one, for colour belts and black belts, it's actually scored a little bit differently.
So if you're a colour belt, you'll actually, your average, so where the judges actually
mark you from.
It's actually from a.
1.1.
So this is your average.
So say you did alright, you did average compared to everyone else, your score for 1, 2, and
3, it'll start from a 1.1.
So if you're less than average in the judges' eyes, you might go down to, say for your power
and speed, you might get a 1 or even a 0.9.
If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So in this category, you need to obviously get as high as you can.
If you're a black belt, generally, depending on the competition, you will be scored from
a 1.3.
So 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So say your power and speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average, it wasn't amazing, it might be just a 1.3.
So that's your average.
So 1.3, but let's say you didn't shout very loud.
So your expression of energy, your average was 1.3, it might drop to, say, a 1.0.
So with this one, we'll come over down to this side.
So with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10.
So let's see.
And for presentation, we had 0.7, 1.2, 1.3, 1.4, 1.5, 1.6, 1.7, 1.8, 1.9, 1.9, 1.10, 1.11,
1.11, 1.12, 1.12, 1.13, 1.13, 1.14, 1.14, 1.15, 1.16, 1.17, 1.18, 1.19, 1.20, 1.21, 1.22, 1.23.
So you added 3.7.
Let's say you made 15 mistakes.
So with this one, obviously don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
This is with the judges.
We have three judges usually at the panel and each judge, obviously it's very subjective.
So from their point of view, you might've made a lot of mistakes or you may have made not
a lot of mistakes as well.
So that's why we have the three judges and we average it out as well.
Okay.
So say we did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes.
So if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.5.
So you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5.
So this would be your accuracy score.
So with our presentation like before, we're saying we've got a 4.0, minus 1.5, which equals
2.5.
So this would be your accuracy score.
So with our presentation like before, we're saying we've got a 4.0, minus 1.5, which
equals 2.5.
So this would be your accuracy score.
So if you added these numbers at the, after the judges finish scoring, so you would get
for this pattern, a 6.2, which is actually very good.
So I'll just talk about a little bit more now about this number here.
So if you're a color belt out, if you're a yellow or above and you do your patterns,
it's not uncommon generally for a color belt.
The average is about a 5.5.
four to five so if you get a number between uh four and five out of ten for your pattern
that's actually uh generally considered pretty good so anything above that uh you can consider
yourself pretty good uh if you're a blackboard the average would say because um we're talking
here about the higher presentation as an average anything from five to two sorry five to six
is actually considered uh pretty pretty good and anything over a seven is actually considered
almost world class so if you get a seven for any of your patterns you generally need to pat
yourself on the back you did an amazing job so we just went through our poomsae scoring so just
remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation is a 6.0 accuracy is judged during your pattern
presentation is
after and then we get the two scores that we add up and we get that number so with this one
obviously uh say i was uh i was judge number one i would give you a 6.2 there was another judge on
the other side maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than i did and maybe this one would be a little
bit lower it might be a five point something another judge on the other side they scored a
little bit higher so we'd get the three numbers and then we'd average that as well so
uh you hope this uh helped you guys so uh make sure you enjoy your poomsae competitions and
anytime make sure obviously you record down your numbers as well
while you're watching but we cannot pause this time you're gonna be like a judge of your own
performance okay yeah and then after your poomsae you rate your power
and speed coordination for them and expression and finishing when you're ready we can start
okay
so
so so
um
Thank you.